our our next speaker is my good friend
and colleague Muhammad he's going to
talk about just a few seats more the
inflated value of network data for
distribution please thank you as you can
see I mean it's a co-author in this
paper and together with Suraj who is now
teaching a class on Zoom uh both of them
are fantastic co-authors I learned a lot
from them and uh this paper wouldn't
have existed without everything at one
of them
uh so uh it would have existed without
me so uh let me jump into the problem uh
directly
which is this uh so I'm gonna talk about
the optimal optimal sitting problem and
the problem is uh pretty simple to State
you have a social network on N people
and you have some diffusion model in
mind so one example of a diffusion model
is this classic independent Cascade
model if I inform or infect someone
they're gonna inform or infect their
neighbors with some probability
and they will infect their neighbors
with some probability again and so on
and you have a budget of s seats
and you want to inject this infection or
information uh in the network and your
objective function is potentially to
maximize the total size of diffusion so
this is a very well known problem uh and
uh you want to choose this optimal as
seeds now if you have three seeds and I
give you this network everyone in this
room is gonna tell me who are the
optimal three seats if I give you a
network that is a little bit more
complex it's not as easy to find who are
the optimal C's this is a sub network of
Facebook
uh and in general camper clementardos in
a classic paper which is now I think
five digit cited uh they show that this
problem is MP complete
and You observe the complete Network yes
You observe I'm gonna go there so that's
that was a very good question that uh we
this the Assumption here is that you
observe the complete Network you just
this is just a computational challenge
now uh this problem has a lot of
applications in a lot of fields I mean
I'm an economist the fusion of
microfinance in economics and generally
development economics is a field that
has picked up this problem you want to
spread some information in these
Villages about some farming technology
uh in the second paper or some
microfinance product in this first paper
or some insurance product in some other
papers
uh there are there are a lot of papers
recently by a group of researchers about
teaching people about how to prevent HIV
and then this is a problem that is
started from marketing uh this is a
marketing problem so from many years ago
marketing researchers have been thinking
about the applications of this problem
uh political scientists sociology and so
on now when we have a problem that is MP
complete but we like to solve it because
it has a lot of applications we
typically go after heuristics
so there is a vast literature on
heuristics for the optimal ceiling
problem
now I'm not gonna go through all of
these heuristics it's going to take a
lot of time but all of them have the
following like uh big picture framework
uh you give me the network I observe it
and then through some computational
feasible method I'm gonna rank all nodes
of the network from one to n and then I
pick the top as people
uh so uh let me tell you a little bit
about the findings of this uh big
literature uh
and the microphone is over there
so that seems sort of a little funny the
way you describe it because
once I choose the top I may know that
the next five are useless because
they're almost as good as the top but
they're sort of neighbors of it and I
actually so wouldn't your typical greedy
algorithm be slightly different from
what you said not just absolutely
absolutely the the I there are papers
actually even here that are in this
literature that do this adaptive so when
I first pick the first one I go on
second uh speak the second one like
running a new algorithm instead of
thinking of it as a static problem it
turns out that this Dynamic optimization
doesn't add a huge value in most cases
but uh you can add all of those papers
here too I think even I mean and his
students or Russian Handler I forgot
towards the other student they have a
paper on this uh like Dynamic
optimization in this problem and you can
add all of them here the key that I want
to emphasize here is that all of these
require Network information now you
could be a storm and do something that's
computationally feasible but not a
static but you do you do need the
network information
now in a way the the whole like you can
summarize a lot of the papers in this
literature with this code which is the
concluding paragraph of energy changes
uh which say this has this network
targeting has important implications for
policy to pick the right people to
inform in order to ensure that a new
idea or a product or a piece of
information which is the maximum number
of people
uh this is uh the reason I picked this
is that this is now the like this open
the literature in in economics of uh
networks uh but there are other papers
that do this in different settings and
all of these are important papers so
they do experiments uh and so on and
this is another paper about farming
technology that has the same results
now
what we're gonna do uh we're gonna start
from these uh two questions that were
basically asked in order to find these
optimal seeds you need network data and
uh of course you also need computational
power if you want to do actual Optimum
but even for these heuristics you need
network data and network data is both
expensive
uh especially in this field settings you
can have the Facebook network data but
uh but but for like a real world network
data to inform people about something
it's pretty expensive to have precise
network data and in fact you can almost
never have a good network data in action
uh like this paper by manager Tower who
is a like really amazing data set it's
public and online anyone here who is
interested can go and see the data set
five percent of nodes who not had any
links in the data and then I went and
asked these these people who are all
some of them are my colleagues at the
Stanford I was like what's happening why
these people have no connections and it
turns out in the like two or three times
they did the survey of the network they
were not available in their home so this
is a natural limitation of data that you
have
so the question is what can you do in a
world in which network data is imperfect
it's super expensive and so on there are
a couple of papers in economics that
address this problem
the first one is by the same four
co-authors they published in review of
economic studies and what they say is
that hey let's try to find Central
people without the full network data or
by going and asking different people in
the village about their friends and
friends of friends and use local
information to identify the gossips
the second paper says let me sample 10
of the network 20 of the network and
then use some fancy econometrics to
reconstruct the whole networking
structure
what we're going to do here uh as
theorists we're going to take this
approach to extreme we're gonna ask what
if you do not have any network data to
begin with
uh and how we're gonna do that uh the
next five minutes of the talk is gonna
tell you everything about the message of
this paper uh you can then leave and go
and have your coffee uh but what I'm
gonna do uh anyone here can sit down a
couple of hours this afternoon and do it
I'm gonna take the diffusion of
microfinance paper
and uh do a simulation redo their
simulations and then ask a different
question what I'm gonna do so before
telling you what I'm gonna do let me
spend one minute to tell you what they
did
so in this paper they went and collected
the network data of uh 75 Indian
Villages by asking people about whom do
you go to church with whom do you borrow
money from whom do you get rice from and
so on
so they have this network data which is
empirical and available
and then uh the microfinance company
went and informed a bunch of seats 10 to
15 people in each Village
and then researchers observe who were
the seeds and then who were informed
in this process about the existence of
the microfinance product
and they also know who picked up the
product they know that these people were
informed and they chose to participate
and get a loan
okay so this is an amazing Micro Data
that you have on this diffusion process
in these Villages and the nice thing is
that these Villages are far enough that
you can look at them as independent
samples
then they were like okay let's estimate
the model of diffusion for this for this
uh process they were like okay people
get informed once informed they choose
to participate or not with some
probability P so reduce form weight to
model their decision making
and then if I participate I'm going to
inform my friends with probability CP if
I do not participate I'm gonna inform my
friends with probability cm
we are not going to impose any
assumptions on whether CP is more than
CN or not I mean we naturally expect CP
to be more than cm and then the whole
diffusion stops after cap T periods okay
so I inform I mean I mean inform Zealand
neon informs bryony and then the
diffusion stops it turns out this T is
not super important and binding
so then you're using this amazing data
of diffusion and networks they estimate
these parameters these are the
parameters they have a range these are
the midpoints of the range the results I
will show you will go through for any
point in the range
so what I'm going to do now uh using
this the paper shows that
in The Villages that nodes with
eigenvectors higher eigenvector
centrality were seated these Villages
had higher total diffusion
or in villages that nodes with a notion
that they Define called diffusion
centrality uh they're seated
You observe even more diffusion
diffusion centrality is a measure
between degree centrality how many
friends you have and eigenvector
centrality which thinks about your
friends or friends and your friends or
friends and so on
so what I'm gonna do here is to compare
diffusion centrality which requires
network data
to an algorithm that requires no network
data at all which is random City
the only thing we need to implement a
random seeding is a list of people who
live in the village
so this is uh probably the main figure
I'm going to show you uh let me walk you
through this slowly uh so that we know
what we are doing on the x-axis I have
the number of seeds on the y-axis I have
the total diffusion let me start from
here and tell you what I'm doing here uh
so for this blue dot over here
what we are doing is to see the highest
diffusion Central node in every one of
these 75 villages
inform them about microfinance and then
run this diffusion model so that node is
going to participate with probability 24
percent
then they're going to inform their
friends with these probabilities and the
whole diffusion stops after seventh
period
okay so the network is data we are not
imposing any network model it's data
so for this one if I do that the total
number of people who would be eventually
informed about microfinance is 127.
I do the same thing here uh we say hey
let's go and see one node randomly and
simulate this model and the data and you
you get 60.
which immediately tells you the result
of the literature is absolutely right
like careful sitting uh is going to be
highly valuable for you
then we continue doing the same thing by
two three four and five seeds going
after the top two diffusion Central top
two two random seeds and so on and if
you look at this uh from the x-axis
perspective you will see that random
with four seeds will do better than
diffusion Central seeding with one
so this could be three extra seats this
could be like uh times three seats this
could be like e to power something seeds
uh that's that's a that's a question
that theory will help us to answer but
at least in this example we observed
that a few more seeds in this case three
was enough how big was the village uh
these are Villages of size around 200.
oh so that's that's a that's a few on
average
uh so we so this was kind of uh
interesting and important for for
potentially policy because you need no
network later you can just go after
random seeds
uh we were like maybe this is just
expected value let's look at other
moments maybe you care about variance
second second moment and third moment
and so on it turns out that even if you
look at the whole distribution
this is a distribution of total number
of informed people empirical
distribution for random seeding with one
seat which is pretty terrible relative
to Optimal ceiling with one seat
once I have random seating with three
this red line red curve that you see
here it's beating the optimum with one
so two extra seats is enough for random
to beat the optimum empirically speaking
in a first order as the classic Flash
Just Like A first order stochastic
dominance that you see this blue curve
is an algorithm that I will tell you
about this omniscient it's better than
the optimum and even random with four
extra seats is is even beating that so
we will talk about that but uh I just
wanted to say that it's not about
expected value uh random with a few
extra seats first order sarcastic you
don't
uh and then we were like okay maybe it's
just about this paper let's go this
literature has like thousands of paper
let's look at some other ones uh for
example this is for another paper
experiment in villages in China uh we
use their model of diffusion their data
these are the heuristics that they used
as using network data this is random
seeding and again random with five is
better than uh network-based seeding
victory
and it works for like every number here
so uh we were is it incidental is it
fundamental like What's Happening Here
uh and then uh
in the next 45 minutes of this this talk
I'm gonna convince you that this is not
incidental this is actually a
fundamental property of the sir or
independent Cascade diffusion model that
random with a few extra seeds is going
to be optimal
the question we're going to ask in
precisely yes
a naive question
you are randomly seeding how many times
are you repeating this random seating I
mean are you talking about on average
effect are you talking about with
probability one what is your measure
the question is if because you can use
microphone but how did simulations these
are all like uh like think of them as
what they call the simulations we are
taking averages so this is for this one
I see the most diffusion Central node of
each a 75 Village and I simulate like
thousands of times
so this is the average from here this is
the average this one is the empirical
distribution of all those simulations
okay thank you
so so we were talking about some kind of
improvement on average right this could
be that if you see
particularly badly you will have a worse
result than you would well this is not a
worst case analysis you're right but
this one is not the average this one is
the distribution this is saying that
even with Optimum you can have terrible
outcomes
and in a first order a stochastic
fashion random will do better even for
for any moment you look at basically
thank you oh great thank you for the
question so here is the theoretical
question we're going to ask
in one world ignore all the heuristics
and computational feasibility in one
world you have access to infinite
computational power you're gonna look at
the network and Seed s nodes optimally
in the different world in a second world
you're gonna ignore the network
structure entirely and see it S Plus X
node randomly the question is for what
value of x that second world beats the
first one
and Theorem One X is some number between
1 and N the number of people in the
village there is a number there so
that's an easy theorem to prove uh the
second theorem is that we will show
conditions under which X is pretty small
so this is a way to quantify the value
of both network data and computational
Power
I will have to emphasize before going
into Theory and graph theory that we are
not saying this is random seeding is a
policy proposal you can do better than
random easily by choosing friends of a
random randomly chosen note for example
this is a theoretical Benchmark that
helps you compare the value of
collecting network data and optimizing
over the network with
seating more
okay so it's a comparison between these
two uh auction theorists of the crowd
should remember Beulah and calempara
from this comparison they say let's
compare optimal actions with simple
actions with one extra bidder and see
which one is better
so this is a question in in that spirit
and the main theorem is going to say in
uh under some conditions random with a
few extra seats beat Optimum the theorem
has a lot of Clauses so the one
condition is that the diffusion should
be viral if the diffusion turns out to
be very small then a random is not going
to perform substantially better than
like it's not going to outbeat like it's
gonna it's not going to be better than
Optimum but then even Optimum is going
to be pretty small
well and then the diffusion model is
important uh so there are diffusion
models under which actually careful
seating and network data is highly
valuable and then I have to tell you
what do I mean by a few we will get
there
great so I will tell you the model uh
and then the main theorem and proof
ideas the results will go through even
for parallel networks uh which is
probably the interesting case that even
in parallel networks it you don't want
to go after the the most central people
and then uh I will probably have a
little bit of time to tell you about
limitations
of the results if you change the
diffusion model or if you focus on the
speed of diffusion as an objective
function uh or if you want to minimize
diffusion instead of maximizing the
fusion for example by vaccination then
network data ends up being actually more
valuable than what we show
but
so this is the one slide every Network
model every Network paper has I have a
Social Network and and nodes uh I'm
going to focus on undirected network for
now this is the fusion of information or
flu if you and I see each other both of
us are going to exchange this this
uh and then uh you have S seeds Okay so
you have constant number of seeds
anything more than one
so here is the diffusion model
and many people here know this model
because it's called Sir or independent
Cascade a Time equal to t uh this node
is informed
the informed node has a chance to inform
his friends with probability C
uh some of these are realized some of
them are not and then this is the newly
informed note
now I could let this guy to inform his
neighbors in multiple periods doesn't
make any difference for the results
if he can inform his friends forever
then the problem becomes kind of
uninteresting because in the long run
everyone would be informed so I'm gonna
just simplify everything and assume this
guy has only one shot to inform his
friends now this newly informed guy at t
equal one has a shot to him for his
friends we'd probably see
or some of these are realized some of
them are not these are the newly
informed notes again they have a shot to
inform their friends at time too
the process continues this is the newly
informed guy informs his friends that
one is the newly informed guy does not
inform his friend and the diffusion
stops
okay so there is no cap T anymore the
diffusion stops when there is no new
node who can inform their friends
so these black nodes are now my informed
notes these now know that if you the
microfinance product exists
uh the size of this set the number of
black nodes is going to be my objective
function
okay so we're gonna focus on that you
can change that objective function to
variance or speed we are going to focus
on the expected value of this this set
okay so let me summarize campaign
retardos for you in one slide uh we are
going to use different notation uh but
exceeding a strategy is a mapping from
Network You observe the network you know
how many seats you have to a set of
nodes it's a set function an example of
a seating strategy is to see nodes with
maximum degree another example is
Christians like a smart idea of doing it
dynamically another idea is random Civic
these are all examples of seeding
strategies as a function of your network
how many seats you have and you're
seeding a strategy this will generate a
stochastic set of eventual informed
nodes
right the set of those black nodes that
I showed you that's a stochastic set
it's a functional realization of
probability disease
the size of this set divided by the
total number of people isma is is our
objective function
okay so if you want to maximize the
expected fraction of nodes that are
informed by choosing a seating strategy
which is a pretty complicated object
it's a it's a set function
from all networks and number of seats so
this is the optimized optimal problem
optimal seeding problem given a network
and number of seeds you want to choose a
seeding strategy to maximize this
function and this is a problem that kkt
showed that this is a chemical Tardis
showed that is MP complete
uh we don't know how to analyze this uh
in a in an elegant fashion uh instead of
analyzing Optimum and comparing it with
random we are going to analyze a
different algorithm that's better than
Optimum
for those of you who have not seen this
omniscient idea before this is going to
be a moment of epiphany it's actually a
common technique in computer science uh
it's and it's kind of simple it says
suppose you have a planner or a like
designer
uh who knows everything about all the
realizations of those probabilities okay
it's like it's you're kind of dealing
with the God who knows the future who
knows who's going to talk to whom now
choose the optimal s seats you can only
do better than Optima you can always
ignore that information but you can also
use it so this is a better than Optimum
algorithm that turns out to be much more
attractive
okay let me tell you what's the
intellectual exercise and then I get I
take questions uh we are going to start
with random seeding
if you go to the field and collect
network data you're gonna use some
heuristic like eigenvector centrality or
a smart heuristic and your network is
going to be imperfect
so the Practical value of going to the
field and collecting network data the
Practical Gap is the gap between these
two if I say random with one more seed
is going to be this you know that the
value of this exercise that you're gonna
do is one more seat
now
I can be more generous we can say hey
suppose you observe the network letter
with no error
in fact suppose you have computational
power you can even choose the optimum
not heuristics
and even more generous suppose you know
everything about the future
then we're gonna show that actually
random with a few extra seeds is going
to beat even the omniscient
okay so everything else is kind of in
between so the bounds we're going to
show you uh theoretical bounds are so in
a way too much too generous
uh
okay so this is exactly the graph I
showed you at the beginning of the talk
this is random with one seed Optimum
random with two extra seats omniscient
random bit three extras four extra seats
that was a question yeah to what extent
is your argument
thank you to what extent is your
argument that if I do random in a couple
of time steps I'm gonna hit the people
that the optimal police should have
targeted anyway
we will almost never do that yeah you
will never hit the optimal policy
because
in a network of like enlarge and if you
want to see it five people it's very
unlikely you see one of those no no what
I'm saying is that in the next couple of
hops of the process oh God naturally it
would hit the central person yeah that's
a that's a that's basically you you're
like 75 of the proof yeah but in
practical sense my feeling is that like
you know my chance of like me affecting
a meme versus I mean affecting me it's
not symmetric well these models are
usually symmetric exactly that's a great
question I wanted to have this
conversation when we get to the
limitations
so
you will see the proof uh but or you can
read it in the paper a crucial step in
the proof is that uh this isn't like the
chance that I in fact I mean is same as
the chance that I mean infects me which
is a very good assumption for diffusion
of say covet or infectious diseases or
even some piece of fact that people
share but the chance that I can
influence Lionel Messi is much less than
the chance that he can send a message to
me or influence me
so in a way the way we look at these
results is a joint rejection of the
the fusion model that have been used to
estimate these processes in practice in
economics and other fields
and the diffusion model and and sorry
the importance of seeding so either the
diffusion model is different from these
models that we have been using to
estimate the Practical diffusions or
seeding cannot be as important as we
thought
so which one is true is is to be decided
by by experiments but it's a joint
rejection
I will show you one empirical evidence
that an RCT was done in practice that
shows doesn't look like seating is as
important careful
oh great so let me uh show you the main
theorem in order to prove any results we
have we need a network model we are
going to work within homogeneous random
graphs uh many people here know how they
work uh but let me explain it anyways so
each node in this model has a type
and uh then there is a kernel function
that's it's a symmetric function that
says for each two types what is the
probability that they are connected
so you have this uh this this this model
uh and you can have as many types as you
like in fact uh you can have even
uncountably many types
but here I'm going to focus on finite
types
so then you can form a graph which uh
the graph of K and each element of this
graph is going to be the expected number
of type J friends of a type I
note
this would be your uh graph you can
calculate the largest eigenvalue of this
graph it's going to be a useful object
so we're going to analyze the diffusion
model in in homogeneous random graphs
as as one as one uh
relatively General Network structure so
here is uh the main theorem I need one
more uh definition uh so remember this H
function little H function was the
expected value of the number of informed
nodes for a given Network number of
seeds and seeding a strategy so here the
expectation was taken over the
realization of the diffusion process I'm
going to take another expectation over
the realization of the network model
which is this inhomogeneous random graph
and then I'm going to call it the Big H
so this simply says if you draw a random
Network
from inhomogeneous cyanogra and you have
S seeds and use the seeding strategy s
what is f what is the fraction of nodes
that are going to be informed
so here is the result uh if the largest
eigenvalue of this graph is more than
one other communication probability C
uh then there is a function a constant
Alpha which is basically the size of the
giant component of the network that the
gap between random seeding uh with X
extra seats and omniscient seeding
exponentially vanishes
so we'll see again C is the
communication probably the chance that
if I inform I mean he's gonna inform his
friends each one of them
right
it's the infection rate so this is I
mean many people here are saying how the
proof will work this is effectively the
condition under which your network has a
joint component
oh so you are not if you like it's more
than one then you have a giant component
and in that world the gap between
these two exponential advantages
so ttk is the spectral radius right it's
Dominator
these case government Target value right
if this is the largest eigenvalue of
your yeah
so for evolutionary
now this is for uh the world in which
you have viral diffusion if you don't
have viral diffusion then this condition
fails then random will not actually be
able to compete with omniscience but
even omniscient in the in the like as as
n goes to Infinity the size of the
diffusion is
thank you
it's like
you Alpha depends then on which
parameters then it depends on the
parameters of the net four can see yeah
and can you
do you have an explicit form of alpha
whether this is existential
well it's a universal constant Alpha
independent of X this is a very strong
indeed statement yes it's a it's
independent of X it's a function of the
parameters of the inhomogeneous random
graph the kernel function and C you know
we we know like very a lot about this
Alpha for like random graph or a bunch
of other networks uh I mean is my
encyclopedia and yeah I ask about from
them do we know more about generally in
homogeneous random graph sulfur I don't
think so so to capture something because
it's a kind of probability of existence
of something so what is a kind of in
heuristic intuitive level what Alpha is
capturing
it's the survival probability of the of
the of uh the probability that the
branching process of this network uh
goes for an infinitely many steps
cool uh so you can apply this result to
early to show any random graphs uh
go ahead I didn't I mean
I feel that there is like a information
theoretic result you can prove here that
if your graph is so boring that you
could not reach the few steps in a few
steps a couple of random roads then
there's nothing to be said if your graph
is interesting
then you're optimal policy catches in a
few steps random nodes if you have
seeded those notes by symmetry you will
get to the optimal seats anyway I guess
without like kind of like a fundamental
without characterizing anything about
how the graph looks like
but I mean we haven't thought about that
oh it's
quite far
so when you prove your theorem if you
don't have t equals seven you have t
equals infinity right
I think because in that node actually in
the only
in the opening whatever knowing Network
there is no optimal seat if you choose
any seed in the largest component that's
optimal
and so it doesn't really matter so
there's no notion of I see it random and
then seven seeds later I reach a mean
because I mean it's as good as me we are
both in this component
s
right so that would be interesting so
you can probably prove your horizon as
something like block n or something yeah
if yeah if T is of the order of like the
diameter of the network say the maximum
distance in the network which is
typically like five or six in the
networks we care about then this
probably goes through immediately you're
gonna reach everyone anyways in five or
six steps we do have we do know that for
one or two steps uh even for erdog chain
you're not gonna do uh very well so oh
yeah that would be interesting that's
definitely something we haven't we
haven't proved theorems
oh great so this you can apply to Elder
training and the theorem just changes
from instead of eigenvector a larger
signing Vector to average degree D times
the communication probability being more
than one which is very familiar postcode
this is just saying that if each person
on average informs one other person or
more then random sitting is gonna
Define
um like beats omniscient seating pretty
quickly uh and if this is less than
equal to one then uh you're not gonna do
well anyways even with omniscience
so great so let me show you a little bit
of proof ideas I know many people here
already know what is the proof uh but uh
it's it's a it's a percolation idea and
I'm gonna quickly review it uh so it's
about communication and not friendship
what's the idea you have a social
network
a different way to look at the diffusion
instead of looking at this Dynamic
process is to assume there is a God
who knows who is going to talk to whom
okay so for each one of these two uh if
I'm thinking about diffusion of kovit
that if I mean and I see each other I
have Kobe that infect him with some
probability and vice versa I can toss a
coin with probability C
and keep those links with probability C
and kill them with probability one minus
C
so these are the nodes that they would
infect each other if one of them is
infected okay so I'm just looking at the
future if I inform I mean he's going to
inform his friends with travel to c x
and I can say hey but I already know
you're gonna inform this guy but not
that guy
this is a static view to diffusion so
these links are irrelevant the fact that
we are friends is like Irrelevant for
diffusion it's important whether you're
gonna actually inform me with that
probability c i can kill all of these
links
and this is what we're going to call the
communication Network so I have a
question there yeah
so
at least if I I don't
think this is actually quite the right
Network because
I if you get infected you throw some
probability of infecting me if I get
infected I have some probability of
infecting you and so the Edge from me to
you and the act from you to me and this
God observed network is actually or so
it's an oriented network but some edges
yeah perfect so so I don't think this is
actually the right Network yeah
Christian is always uh three slides
ahead of me so here I'm copying the
event that if I see I mean I will inform
him and if he he sees me he will inform
me these two events happen in a couple
fashion uh in general it could be that
if I see him I will infect him and if I
see sees me he doesn't in fact or inform
me that means uh this graph is gonna be
directed in that world we look like
something like this uh I'm not going to
show you the proof for that but the same
result goes through here uh I'm gonna
start with that simpler Assumption of
coupling these two uh but then instead
of dealing with giant components uh
you're gonna deal with a strongly
connected giant components uh who are
who are in here I will tell you actually
a little bit how the proof will change
here let me continue with this
Assumption of cup coupling these two
events thank you Christian for for
asking so this is called the
communication network uh and computer
scientists call it percolated Network
now why this is a this is a fantastic
Network to look at because if some node
in a connected component of this network
is infected or informed
I'm going to continue with informed it's
informed everyone here will be informed
I know it's anti that if this guy is
informed they're going to talk if this
guy is informed these people are going
to talk and so on
so if I tell omniscient hey omniscient
uh you know everything about the future
and you have one seat where will you put
it omniscient will immediately say here
if I tell amnition you have two seats
where you will you put it one would be
here in this component one would be here
omniscient is super smart it's not gonna
put two here
and if I say three it continues so
omniscient is going to be extremely
smart put one seed in every connected
component of this graph
random is going to hit each one of them
with proportional probability
so if you know the distribution of the
sizes of the connected components of the
communication Network
uh you're done with the proof
because for the omniscient you just sum
up the top as components for random you
just hit them proportionally
and that is what uh erdo shiny and Paula
versatile and all this graph Theory
amazing literature has done if
the largest the largest eigen value of
your inhomogeneous random graph
is more than one over C the
communication probability we know that
you have a
largest you have a constant size giant
component and everything else is going
to be very small
if this is less than equal to 1 over C
we know that this should be corrected
this was for erdog we know that all
components are linear size or sublinear
size
we know exactly that they are login size
for General inhomogeneous random graph
we know that there's something here
so all components are small relative to
the size of the graph
okay so for erdog Cheney this would be D
and that would be D and these are all
logging size
now how the proof proceeds random
seeding is gonna hit the giant connected
components with this probability
so for any any number of seeds you have
there is a there is an extra chance you
hit this and everything is sorry for
being the nasty mathematician but I
think you need an extra assumption that
your
operator Kappa is irreducible because
otherwise you could actually have two
giant yes I should have been more thank
you for being the nasty mathematician it
should be irreducible uh the the
operator copper should be irreducible uh
it was actually one more condition to uh
go back to the paper
you're absolutely right yeah
yeah
great thank you for collecting uh or or
clarifying this this assumption that you
need uh for this this operator Kappa
should be irreducible you cannot have
like the the two disconnected Parts it
cannot be reduced should be irreducible
so under that condition then you're
gonna hit the join components with some
uh exponentially going to one
probability and a small elements are
irrelevant so omniscient is gonna put
one seat here and a bunch of seeds in
the largest of these small components
but those are so small so what you care
about is hitting the joint component
so I'm here omniscient is going to be
very smart pick the largest of the small
components you're gonna actually
potentially do terrible because there is
a low chance do you hit the largest of
the small components but even if you sum
these uh so long as your number of seeds
is constant or doesn't grow too fast the
sum of them would remain sub-linear so
the fraction of nodes that are informed
is a steel zero
now of course these are all limit
results and to see whether they make
sense for real world networks uh we are
going to do we have done already
simulations and you have to look at
empirics and simulation uh but uh this
this tells you what's happening
great so and then we have the Christians
uh
uh complaint uh which was right I
basically partner complaint number uh
yeah
which is I I like to you I mean in a way
it's like coupled this too if you have a
if you have actually
the events that I inform I mean is
separate from the event that he informs
me then your communication graph looks
like this I have to toss the coin uh
with probability C for each Direction
and then we know that you will have a
strongly giant connected component in
the same threshold fashion what this
will change is kind of cute
if I give one seat to the omniscient the
omniscient is not going to put the seat
here anymore
it's gonna put it here
because then I'm gonna go through this
path and then hit the strongly connected
giant component
okay this is kind of too good to be true
it turns out that uh the we can prove
that the size of this path is also order
login it's pretty small so this doesn't
make any difference the other bound we
could find in the literature was written
if anyone knows a better bound uh that
we haven't cited let us know but
this is what I've learned
uh during the course of this paper
great so let me show you a few uh
extra points uh how about uh Leo and
Selena how does this result goes through
even for power on it Forex the intuition
is just this one example uh suppose I
have this network you have the star in
the middle and everyone is connected to
this star
communication probability is 0.5 I have
a thousand people surrounding this star
uh this this Central node optimal
seating is going to hit the center the
total diffusion would be 500.
random seating is gonna see the leaf
total diffusion would be 250. let me
bring these two here random with a few
extra seats one of them is going to hit
the center with exponentially
high probability in fact with four extra
seats uh you are already
98 of the optimal
okay so that's that's basically the
question that was just asked which is
once you believe in this model of
diffusion
sir independent Cascade s-e-r-i all of
these models that we work with uh a few
extra scenes are going to quickly reach
to this Central node anyways either in
one bonus step or two steps
and then you're you're good to go
uh putting differently two things in
like intuitively two things can happen
either the network has highly Central
nodes in which case because they are
they are highly centralized
for that precisely for that you're gonna
hit their friends with random sitting or
their friends or friends
or the network does not have highly
Central nodes like evolutionary random
graph in which case who cares about
centrality to begin with
yes
so now in the real world
um so this is not a mathematical right
to take a sort of more a question about
what happens in the real world so in the
real world
um me sort of following Obama may be
pretty high as a probabilities
probabilities that Obama follows me is
pretty low if you random seat somebody
in this huge Twitter Network you will
get the followers of Obama they try to
influence Obama but that is useless and
so your strategy or random strategy
would really not work whereas if I'm on
the
knowing I will see that all the notes
come from Obama to the people out and so
I would seat Obama and I would succeed
by a factor
so
totally so that seems to indicate that
for all internet networks which sort of
have something like
celebrities and non-celebrities Optimum
seating is really much better than
random I don't know I mean this is not a
CRM but it's sort of a suggestion well
totally so your uh
uh yes
which you are next proving yeah the
complaint number uh 33 is accepted no
but but totally uh as I said uh once you
change the diffusion model for example
to a model in which some people actually
we do have examples if I have time I
will show you what they're in the paper
if the if you have a diffusion model in
which Obamas of the world are much more
likely to inform their friends than vice
versa this result will fail uh yeah if
you have limited capacity of listening
like Obama is gonna listen to 100
friends only and everyone is not gonna
listen to more than 100 friends then
these celebrities you're very unlikely
to hit one of the friends of these
celebrities who will inform the
celebrity totally right this results
will fail uh and that's that's a that's
a great next question what we are doing
here just to repeat what what I said
before so in social science uh we kind
of brought this epidemiology models of
diffusion to understand diffusion in in
like human Networks
and you can look at this as a critique
of this exercise this is saying hey this
this model which is fantastic for
epidemiology yes I are independent
Cascade may not be the best model for
many economic interactions we have to
think about this this real world
considerations
great so you can do the same simulation
for Facebook Network the same result
goes through the blue is random I mean
let me not emphasize on this I like this
picture more so we do simulation for all
initial many initial number of seeds
many communication probabilities C and
we look at how many extra seeds random
needs to beat eigenvector centrality
seeding in Facebook Network that we have
it's a network of 5000 people 4 000
people and you look at all numbers the
maximum is five so there's no point in
this space that random needs more than
five to beat eigenvector Central seating
in this network of five thousand people
four thousand people
foreign
yes
what does it mean when it goes negative
it means that oh I love that question
it's actually here to random sitting
sometimes performance better than this
is actually Christian's point so these
seating strategies like eigenvector
centrality go after the node with
highest eigenvector centrality then the
second one then the third one
at some point the marginal value is zero
because these are all connected to the
core of the network
uh random once in a while hits people
here and there and that's actually
better so once you have uh like let me
show you here once you have more than
five or six seeds random beats a few of
these algorithms just because of this so
these are actually bad strategies for
large number of seats you want to follow
Christian's idea that for them
my great idea algorithm
foreign
Factor one minus one over e of optimum
yeah not with respect to omnipotence I
think Justice respect tool
yeah really actually is is performance
through this Dynamics this great idea
stored from the paper it's called
but it's better than just going down the
list yeah
perfect
so let me just tell you about one
empirical study that gets as close to us
testing this result so they didn't do
this to test this result but like
incidentally it's kind of close so the
same four co-authors have this paper in
restart the review of economic studies
they do randomized control trials uh and
uh they have two rcts the first one is
pure information I'm informing people
the second one is about actually how
many people did go and vaccinate
so this one they have six seeds uh they
compare three seeding strategies random
seeding going after old people or
finding the gossip of the village by
local information they ask people who do
you think is the gossip the next person
they form a local network and find the
concept
and then they find that random gets on
average 8.1 people to be informed these
are Villages or Villages of 30 40 people
uh and uh with going after gossip this
local network information you get 11.7
an elderly is worse than wolves the
second experiment is they sell say
people hey go and ask your friends to
actually go and vaccinate
and then they do the same exercise with
six seeds they find that random gets
18.11 and uh
gossip gets 23.
okay so this is fixing the number of
seeds uh Gossip Network seating is
basically is doing better which is
completely consistent with with what we
claim if you're gonna do better but you
can get it like you can we can try to
extrapolate and guess how many extra
seeds you need in these experiments in
order for random to beat here random on
average each random seed is getting
three people uh to adopt two more people
beyond the seat so if we linearly
extrapolate you just need two more seats
to get to 23. even if we just cut it by
saying that each random seed is going to
inform just one other person instead of
two because now we have already informed
six people uh you need three extra seats
to beat uh optimal seating and even if
we just say that each person is going to
adopt only themselves by seeding them
you need less than five extra seats so
that's kind of as close to an experiment
we get it's an RCT so I quite like this
result
great let me uh I have five minutes left
uh let me
not go through all of these
uh so diffusion model model is uh highly
important uh if you generalize this
independent Cascade by the way this is
one of the open questions for students
of the crowd or anyone who is interested
talking about it like what kind of other
diffusion models this goes through
that's a that's an open question we know
that by simulation or proofs some other
diffusion models we can prove for
directed communication for a specific
class of networks we can prove it and
particularly speaking for these two it
goes through Evan Sadler has a paper in
AR in which there is a diffusion game
going on so people make a decision they
update their belief in a Bayesian
fashion everyone was a student that
belong so even for his paper this result
goes through uh but not for all
the classic Model in which this result
will not go through is the threshold
model of diffusion the threshold model
of diffusion says if I inform I mean
he's not none of his friends are going
to be informed if I inform Amin and
yagana and Ilan and they have one friend
that is common and that friend is now
going to be informed because there are
three of his friends this is a great
model for product adoption so that
whenever you have Network externality
this becomes a model and in this case
actually random sitting is gonna do
terrible it's very unlikely for you to
hit two friends of the same person
uh or The Limited capacity model that
gets into Christians or empirical
critique number 33 which is uh if Obama
cannot listen to all of his 70 million
followers then uh then this results May
Fail
uh now let me uh just just continue by
by telling you that
uh
my my favorites uh actually example
which is this uh this result will also
fail for the vaccination problem if you
want to minimize diffusion so you have a
network
someone attacks your network randomly
and hits this guy now you want to defend
the network by vaccination well one
optimal vaccination is gonna pick the
center and the diffusion stops
random vaccination is going to hit the
leaves and they are kind of irrelevant
in this case in order for you to hit the
center you have to randomly hit like 75
percent of the notes to finally get the
center with high probability so it's
very easy to attack a net Forge because
random ceiling is gonna diffuse uh
pretty quickly just a few seeds more is
enough to defend it at least in this
example uh you need uh many more seats
we don't know whether this is the
general result it's kind of interesting
to see whether the vaccination problem
admits oh a similar story
so let me close uh by saying that uh
there are some questions uh
I would like empirical researchers to
ask before going to the field and going
after eigenvector Central uh or like
diffusion Central nodes the first one is
like what is the underlying diffusion
process this is a question that's
important to ask before doing any kind
of diffusion experiment do you hope the
diffusion to go viral if you hope to go
for example think of an election so if
you have to get more than 50 percent of
people to believe in you and anything
less than that gives you a utility of
zero
then you do want the viral diffusion of
something then in that case uh the story
is different than a case in which your
utility is just an increasing function
of the number of people who are informed
there is no step function
now this is an important case for say
vaccination if you need 80 of the people
to believe vaccination is good to get
into Health immunity
it's like that's a that's a that's an
example of this situation uh do you care
about the speed if you care about the
speed then it's important to go for
central people and do you want to
maximize or minimize the fusion uh one
last comment I have is that there is a
statistic that measures the economic
value of network saving the statistical
value is always significant in these
experiments and papers we have seen
like seeding central people is always a
statistically better than randomly
sitting but there is a way to measure
the economic value which is tell me how
many extra seeds I need
uh for a network agnostic strategy like
random seating to get to say 95 percent
or 99 of this network-guided seating
okay this is telling you something about
the fact that like I know how much each
seat costs and if you tell me two more
seeds are enough then I know the value
of my exercise beyond the statistical
significance
we did this for a bunch of papers there
is a python package you can use to do it
for any other paper so for these like
two papers for example uh you need
something between one to three extra
seats to get to
to get to 95 percent of the of the
heuristic that these papers suggest it's
a good heuristic so I find this to be a
to be a good good way at least for
empirical researchers uh to think about
it and I'm gonna close by by this
picture so one nice thing about being in
a business school is that when you write
a paper uh they interview you and your
co-authors they write a piece about it
and then they ask an artist to read the
piece and they picked something and draw
something so this is an artist reading
our interview and turning it into an art
so this is foreign
[Applause]
I have a question and possibly comment
depending on the answer of your on the
question so you said this
you had an undirector link and then you
said in reality it should be
too direct that one going from A to B
and the other did you mean that these
things should be independent and have
the same distribution
uh so
yeah what we are saying here is that the
if I inform I mean he's gonna inform me
with probability C if you inform me I'm
gonna inform I mean with probability C
and these two are independent
so what we need here is that these two
are symmetric
uh in that case uh even these two can
have different probabilities than these
two but we need symmetry in here
so then my comment is that if you have
one Edge going you decide to flip a coin
should there be an edge from A to B and
then you flip another coin should be a
emerge from B to a and I claim that it's
enough to have one one Edge because
rather than having a to b or B to a you
could say I will use the first coin flip
for the first time I might inform
someone
could be the direction and then the
second toss will be the second time you
will use it but then you will you
realize that you will never use it more
than in One Direction so it's enough to
flip one coin so I think you can
actually consider the undirected network
only this is sort of a an old epidemic
result if the things are independent you
don't need to consider the direction you
just you interpret the undirected edge
as if a gets infected
uh he or she will spread it to be
or if B gets infected he or she will
spread it to a because you will never be
considering going in in both directions
yeah but I'm worried about this guy so
if I inform this guy this guy will not
be informed
so sorry your your initial network is a
director Network so uh no the initial
network is a
is a is an undirected Network the
communication has Direction
so if I inform this guy over here uh I
know X Auntie that this guy is not going
to inform this guy back
but this guy's two is going to inform
this guy so I'm not sure if it works
well maybe not I think probabilistically
it's enough to have one Edge but it's a
nice trick but here the seating appears
the sitting is decided after the
appearance of the network so you can't
pull that through it's a very nice trick
but it's not applicable
any more questions concerns
oh
are we going to have lunch
yes that's right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]